notre invité politique ce matin c'est
amélie de montchalin la ministre de la
transformation et de la fonction
publique bonjour à millemont challenge
ou alors nous sommes ensemble pendant 20
minutes pour une interview
en partenariat avec la presse régionale
qui est représenté aujourd'hui par eric
richard journaliste à la nouvelle
république bonjour eric bonjour
alexandre nos jours mais les noms seul
un bonjour alors vous le doute et on va
commencer par parler de la crise
sanitaire avec le calendrier du
déconfinement qui se précise
à la mi mai les terrasses des bars et
des restaurants pourraient rouvrir le
couvre-feu va être allégé les
restrictions de déplacements lever quand
on voit le niveau du virus actuellement
notamment dans les hôpitaux en ile de
france
est ce que c'est le moment de les
confiner la première chose c'est
qu'effectivement nous faisons tous des
efforts qui sont payants puisque la
prestation plutôt encourageant mais il
reste insatisfaisant puisque est pas
suffisant puisque la baisse aujourd'hui
est deux fois moins rapide que celle que
nous avions connu par exemple à
l'automne donc le premier des messages
je crois que c'est extrêmement important
de rappeler à tous que quand le
télétravail les gestes barrière un
certain nombre de précautions absolument
être tenu
parce que les échéances qui ont été
fixés par le président sont la base de
travail sur lesquelles effectivement
nous nous préparons mais il faut bien
être conscient que nous parlons toujours
de vie malheureusement deux morts deux
décès nous avons une arme de plus dans
notre arsenal de bataille qui est le
vaccin mais il faut qu'on reste
extrêmement vigilant je pense qu'il est
déjà très important de nous assurer que
tout le monde comprend bien que oui et
des échéances oui des étapes qui seront
précisées échelonné que nous travaillons
comme le président la rythmique l'a dit
parce que les enfants des écoles
primaires et maternelles pour qui on le
sait la conséquence éducative de cette
crise peut être très lourdes et c'est un
choix politique
un choix collectif démocratique je crois
que nous portons c'est une spécificité
française et que nous assumons mais pour
que tout cela tienne il faut qu'on soit
encore tous très vigilants c'est très
long c'est très pénible
personne ne rêve
oui d'imposer toutes les restrictions
qui sont aujourd'hui sur la table mais
c'est que dans ces méthodes là que nous
travaillons transparence confiance des
étapes des échéances le président a été
très clair dans son discours du 31 mars
c'est notre base de travail mais ça ne
tient que si chacun en responsabilité
fait ce que chacun je crois maintenant
bien compris qu'ils étaient dangereux ou
moins dangereux mais vous le dit les
chiffres sanitaire ne baisse pas assez
vite
est ce que ce calendrier de rouvrir les
terrasses à la mi-mai ça peut tenir
c'est pas gagné c'est pour ça que je
vous dis et des échéances et des étapes
qu'on franchit et une méthode
il ya beaucoup de transparence on gère
pas cette crise par surprise on se fixe
des caps est donc très important je
crois que les français soient associés
aux échéances qu'on se fixe mais qu'on
rappelle bien à chacun que tout ça ne
tient que si chacun en responsabilité et
bien agi en cohérence avec encore une
épidémie que l'on voit partout en europe
1 le nombre de cas en allemagne était à
peu près le même hier qu en france donc
on voit bien que partout la vigilance la
responsabilité son eau là aussi nos
meilleurs êtes vous donc ce cap de la mi
mai il n'est pas certain le président a
admis travail nous nous préparons nous
préparons tous j'ai pas d'annoncé à
faire sur le fait qu'il y aurait un
recul ou pas je vous dis juste ce que
nous préparons ne tient que si chacun en
responsabilité continue de faire ce
qu'il a à faire
un mot sur le couvre-feu eric oui
peut-être que on se rend compte
désormais après plus d'un an de crise
que les français en quelques sortes ont
besoin d'air alors est ce qu'il y a
malgré tout des mesures d'allègement
possible déjà vous avez remarqué que la
manière dont nous vivons cette période
n'est pas la manière dont il a vécu il
ya un an ni à l'automne le fait que nous
puissions tous nous aérer les 10 km
autour de chez nous sans attestation
bien sûr en respectant le fait qu'on
n'ait pas plus que si ce qu'on respecte
les gestes barrière comporte son masque
c'est en soi une évolution
le fait que nous autorisions là aussi ce
nombre d'activités sportives de plein
air pour les enfants
on a bien sûr adapté mais à nouveau je
le redis nous ne prenons pas ces mesures
par dogmatisme ou par envie le principe
de réalité c'est que c'est un sujet de
vie et de mort et qu'il nous faut donc
être très vigilants la vaccination
progresse à un rythme désormais très rap
de plus de deux millions et demi de
vaccination par semaine on est au dessus
des 13 millions aujourd'hui de personnes
qui ont déjà reçu une première dose et
ça c'est aussi une course contre la
montre qui d'ailleurs se déploie avec un
engagement je voudrais vraiment salué à
la fois des personnels soignants des
élus dé perdre des agents des
collectivités locales
il ya aussi une très grande mobilisation
derrière ces chiffres parfois on oublie
que des hommes et des femmes dans nos
hôpitaux des hommes et des femmes qui
s'organisent pour l'accession et des
hommes et des femmes malheureusement qui
sont malades et à qui je crois nous
devons collectivement beaucoup de
vigilance dans chacun de nos actes
et justement sur la vaccination le
gouvernement communique de façon assez
positive emmanuel macron dit on est sur
la bonne voie mais quand on regarde les
classements mondiaux les classements
mondiaux à 1020 vous aimez bien les
évaluations les baromètres et justement
quand on regarde les classements
eh bien la france elle est au delà de la
30e place mondiale est ce que c'est
acceptable aujourd'hui en europe d'un
fait un choix que tous les européens
soient reçoivent les doses au même
rythme selon leur population et bien je
peux vous dire qu'en europe la france
est dans les tous premiers voire parfois
même la première ça dépend des jours en
termes de vaccination par rapport à sa
population
c'est un choix politique nous ne
voulions pas organiser une guerre des
doses du du plus offrant sur au sur le
voyez la sortie des usines
c'est un je crois qu'ils ne l'ont fait
nous accélérons nous produisons plus
nous produisons en france et vous voyez
qu'aujourd'hui nous vaccinons deux
millions et demi de personnes par
semaine
effectivement je vais pas vous dire
qu'il ya pas eu décalage des choses à
ajuster
c'est d'ailleurs en tant que ministre
une méthode que je défends nous avons
d'abord et avant tout à ne jamais nous
entêter quand il les choses qui ne
fonctionnent pas quand ça part pas comme
ça devrait comme ça ne va pas assez vite
nous nous ajustons c'est la responsable
du politique et c'est la responsabilité
du politique avec son administration
c'est en tant que ministre de la
fonction publique et la transformation
public j'en parlais avec le premier mis
sept résidents ce que nous cherchons à
faire c'est pour ça qu'on veut gagner en
efficacité kenya capacités avant les
bonnes compétences au bon endroit et
c'est pour ça qu'on aime aussi une
réforme de la haute fonction publique
très profonde
est-ce qu'on voit bien qu'il nous faut
en toutes circonstances être capables de
nous adapter de trouver la rapidité les
bonnes compétences au bon endroit et
donc j'ai pas ici oui on n'est pas dans
l'autosatisfaction
on est très réaliste et on s'adapte
à chaque moment pour que cette épidémie
soi et bien derrière nous plus vite
possible c'est notre souhait c'est le
souhait je crois de l'ensemble des
français de l'ensemble des habitants de
la planète et donc on y travaille un mot
sur le télétravail est fonctionnaire le
télétravail qui est devenu la règle en
effet par tous est possible y compris
dans la fonction publique
alors est ce qu il semblerait que dans
certaines collectivités territoriales
c'est la fonction publique aussi il ya
quelques élèves dissipés est-ce qu'à vos
yeux c'est talent et c'est au
gouvernement de rappeler les consignes
ou est-ce que les présidents de ces
collectivités et les élus doivent le
faire alors première chose tous les
employeurs de notre pays parce que le
télétravail est efficace parce que quand
on fait un travail ont réduit
significativement le risque de se
contaminer et de contaminer les autres
tous les employeurs qu'ils soient
publics privés de collectivités l'état
de petites entreprises aux très grands
groupes industriels sont tenus depuis
maintenant des mois à faire appliquer sa
lé travail et je peux vous dire une
mobilisation générale
je vous donne quelques chiffres dans
l'état 58 % des agents de l'état donc
télétravail et la semaine dernière et
ses 78 % dans les ministères parisiens
donc on est on a fait un effort énorme
quand on ans quand on parle des
collectivités d'abord une grande
majorité des élus des collectivités ont
pris également ce chemin comme tous les
employeurs c'est aussi la responsabilité
de l'employeur de le faire quel que soit
son statut
après je vous rappelle que dans la
constitution des collectivités sont
libres et indépendants de gestion
d'administration et que donc la balle
est dans le camp des élus dans la
manière dont ils mettent en place des
recommandations les recommandations sont
très claires
l'état est d'ailleurs aux côtés des
collectivités par le plan de relance par
un certain nombre de partage de bonnes
pratiques et les préfets qui sont aux
côtés des entreprises et les
collectivités pour faciliter le travail
maintenant je tiens à dire une chose
quand on est employeur public qu'on soit
l'état au conseil précise et on a un
devoir d'exemplarité et donc c'est ce
que je vous dis ce matin les élus sont
responsables et ils doivent être
exemplaires
amélie montchanin vous l'avez dit on va
vous mener la réforme de la haute
fonction publique qui a été dévoilée par
le président la république avant de
parler de la sur la suppression de l'ena
l'école nationale d'administration
un mot sur cette réforme concrètement
qu'est ce que ça va
changer pour nos hauts fonctionnaires ça
va changer des choses pour les
fonctionnaires ça va aussi changer les
choses pour les français on a
aujourd'hui un devoir d'efficacité et un
devoir de confiance
recréer de la confiance entre les
français et leur administration et cette
confiance on peut la récré si on
retrouve collectivement cette capacité à
être efficace est rapide avec beaucoup
plus simple à apporter des solutions sur
le terrain adapté à chaque territoire
les préfets par exemple vous savez c'est
une petite révolution en ce moment sont
et c'est une grande nouveauté depuis les
années 60
tenues de proposer au premier ministre
et unique priorité pour qu'il fasse du
sur mesure sur leur territoire
c'est une révolution parce que c'est
aussi une révolution démocratique
les priorités qui vont se fixer vont
partir des sujets ou peut-être que dans
leur département les choses sont
peut-être plus difficile les résultats
sont pas encore là et c'est pas des
priorités qui vont est défini en chambre
ce sont des priorités qui sont fondées
sur les résultats de nos politiques
publiques qui sont publiés sur le site
du gouvernement est que chaque français
peut consulter dans son département
celui-ci du gouvernement de
téléspectateurs peuvent rentrer leur
code postal
et donc ce baromètre des résultats
normaux ceux qui a progressé en un
département et ceux qui aussi n'a pas
assez progressé dans la réforme de la
haute fonction publique est ce qu'on va
faire comme pour les préfets on veut
cette révolution de l'efficacité du
terrain de la capacité de manière
démocratique aussi à avoir une bien
meilleure évaluation une révolution du
pilotage pour nous assurer que les
hommes et les femmes qui ont des
responsabilités ont des objectifs clairs
des objectifs territorialisée et qui
sont évalués dans leur carrière sur les
résultats qui le fournissent cette
réforme de la haute fonction publique
aujourd'hui ce que je vois après envoyé
15 jours après le discours du président
c'est que les français ils ont bien vu
deux choses qui est au coeur de cette
réforme d'abord que les tout le monde va
commencer sa carrière sur le terrain
parce qu'on peut pas avoir une haute
administration qui juge qu'ils
inspectent qui contrôle qui produit de
la norme sans être allé voir d'abord la
manière dont les politiques publiques se
déploient les difficultés la réalité du
terrain tout le monde commencera sa
carrière sur le terrain la deuxième
chose que cette réforme permet de faire
aussi c'est que nous allons faire
évoluer la formation qu'il ya une école
des cadres de formation continue parce
qu'on a beau
de connecter nos fonctionnaires
davantage au terrain mais aussi
davantage aux enjeux du 21e siècle au
monde dans lequel on vit
et sur ces deux sujets les français sont
extrêmement soutien c'est pas
démagogique gendre guy novès et
démagogique ce qui est parce qu il
serait démagogique
c'est de considérer que tout irait bien
que la confiance serait là que les
caennais au fonctionnaire se ferait sur
leurs résultats et donc on a besoin pour
ses hauts fonctionnaires dont je suis la
ministre et dont je suis fier et je sais
les hommes et les femmes qui s'engagent
chaque jour leur redonner de la
formation continue de la visibilité sur
les carrières de nous assurer qu'on met
les bonnes compétences au bon endroit
qui puisse être formé et que nous qu'à
la fin les français par l'information
sur leur terrain voit que les choses
avancent c'est pour ça qu'on a été élu
nous les politiques on n'est pas élu
pour faire des discours on est élu pour
que sur le terrain les choses changent
et donc pour ça il ya une administration
qu'il faut qu'on soit capable de piloter
avec des bons recrutements avec la bonne
formation avec de l'évaluation et que de
manière démocratique notamment avec ces
nouveaux outils que les français
puissent juger par eux-mêmes aussi
département par département de l'action
que nous nous parlons de la formation de
nos hauts fonctionnaires justement l'ami
alignement challenge puisque la mesure
phare de cette réforme c'est la
suppression de l'ena à l'école nationale
d'administration eric oui vous le voulez
vous l'avez dit cette réforme supprime
l'ena et je dirais que toutes les
grandes écoles doivent cependant se se
remettre en question remettre en
question les profils remettre en
question les contenus de formation s qui
avait pas moyen
je dirais de réformes elena de
l'intérieur là on a un peu l'impression
qu'on casse le thermomètre pour faire
tomber une chef que l'on connaît bien on
dénigre facilement la haute fonction
publique l'ena on s'est un petit peu ce
qu'ils qu'il en a est ce qu'il y a pas
moyen de s'y prendre autrement rien à
rien dans ma bouche ni dénigrement je
crois vous m'avez entendu c'est une
réforme positive pour les hauts
fonctionnaires pour les français vous
savez ce sujet de la réforme de la haute
fonction publique et le sujet de l'ena
il est posé depuis 25 ans de rugby en
1995 jacques chirac annonce qu'il veut
mener cette réforme mais y'a pas au bout
quelques années plus tard nicolas
sarkozy commence sa réforme
puis les empêcher
uniquement parce qu'ils n'avaient pas
les bons outils pour aller où et puis
françois hollande remettre sur le métier
le sujet mais en fait il n'avait pas
envie vraiment de faire la réforme est
donc en fait elle s'est perdue dans les
landes aujourd'hui on appris dans la
république qui a pris des engagements en
2017 qu'il a réaffirmée en 2019 qui ont
fait l'objet d'un débat démocratique
ici au sénat à l'assemblée très
approfondie qui a donc habilités comme
on dit le gouvernement a travaillé sur
le sujet et aujourd'hui vous avez un
président qui tient ses engagements qui
m'a chargé de mener cette réforme et de
la mener à terme c'est quoi cette
réforme c'est de passer d'un modèle ou
l'ena était une école qui classait 80
élèves dont les 15 premiers du
classement
choisissez une carrière à vie puisque
c'était ça qui se passait parfois sans
jamais vraiment passé sur le terrain à
un institut de donc du service public
qui va former non seulement ceux qui
étaient au coeur de l'état mais aussi
avec un tronc commun
les directeurs d'hôpitaux les
administrateurs des collectivités
territoriales
les commissaires de police les
directeurs des administrations
pénitentiaires et surtout une école de
la formation continue que nos cadres de
l'état
quatre supérieurs de l'état se forme au
début leur carrière mais se forme
beaucoup plus souvent dans la carrière
donc c'est une réforme qui n'est pas
qu'un changement de nom c'est une
réforme profonde et ensuite moi je crois
dans un pays qu'il faut être capable à
un moment donné dire vacante depuis 75
ans les choses n'ont pas changé
ça crée des forces ça aussi créé des
choses qu'il faut corriger et donc nous
prenons avec beaucoup de courage et
détermination ce sujet dernière question
autour de l'ena sur la variété des
profils justement qui vont alimenter ce
nouvel institut du service public le
gouvernement lance ce qu'il appelle des
prépas talent c'est à dire aider les
étudiants notamment défavorisés à
préparer l'entrée dans cette école mais
il ya une petite polémique sur ce sujet
puisque au début amélie nonchalant vous
avez souhaité et bien exclure les
étudiants de sciences po et le tribunal
tribunal administratif a retoqué cette
décision au nom de l'égalité entre les
étudiants
quel est le problème avec sciences po il
ya pourquoi pas les exclure
il ya aucun problème est évidemment je
vais pas sur le dos des
préparationnaires mener un combat jeu
irie juridiques ou judiciaires donc
évidemment bien volontiers les étudiants
boursiers de sciences po et de la
sorbonne sont aujourd'hui tout à fait
admis à postuler même quel est l'enjeu
mais au début au début vous souhaitez
mais parce que l'enjeu aujourd'hui c'est
que l'immense majorité de ceux qui
rentrent dans les écoles de la haute
fonction publique aujourd'hui son passé
par sciences po paris et par paris c'est
en mode et dans la promesse républicaine
de notre pays dans la france
d'aujourd'hui est nulle part écrit que
par chance ou par hasard il faut que
vous soyez passés par ces deux
institutions pour devenir un serviteur
de l'intérêt général notre objectif avec
le président c'est de nous assurer qu
aujourd'hui au 21ème siècle
l'ensemble de notre jeunesse talentueuse
méritante qui est à l'université qui
vient des zones rurales
quel que soit le milieu ans qu'elle vous
avez grandi quel que soit le territoire
dans lequel vous avez grandi
si c'est votre projet si vous en avez
les talents et les mérites
vous pouvez avoir accès à une
préparation pour préparer ces concours
dans vos universités partout sur le
territoire
c'est un objectif que nous sommes fixés
que 1700 élèves des universités puissent
préparer ces concours sans avoir à
passer par
voyez les grandes institutions
parisiennes il ya rien contre les
institutions parisiennes mais notre ange
aujourd'hui c'est d'ouvrir le jeu moi
j'aurais vous dire quelque chose
aujourd'hui dans le débat politique sur
ses réformes la haute fonction publique
j'entends deux choses qui me gêne
j'entends d'un côté des anciens
ministres des anciens responsables qui
sont aujourd'hui membres de l'opposition
et qui avaient parfois beaucoup de
mauvaise foi ou beaucoup de facilités
sont contre la réforme parce qu'ils ont
eux même essayer de l'amener et qui ne
sont pas parvenus ont parfois des
regrets ou des remords mais qui du coup
sont contre et puis j'entends et ça ça
me gêne beaucoup plus des anciens hauts
fonctionnaires des gens qui sont partis
dans privé il ya 25 ans des personnes
qui sont des observateurs avisés du
système et qui critiquent la réforme sur
la base de choses que je dois assez
indécente
parfois ils ont vécu d'un système
parfois ils ont bénéficié du système et
parfois d'un certain nombre de ces
dévoiements et je pense qu'il est
aujourd'hui dans le débat public très
important que ceux qui s'expriment sur
le sujet le fasse avec bonne foi le
fasse aussi dans un esprit démocratique
notre pays
les français attendent une
administration plus efficace
c'est ça que nous devons faire évoluer
et la ministre que je suis
pas dans le dénigrement mais pas dans la
démagogie et dans une réforme d'abord
nous voulons faire émerger une nouvelle
génération de hauts fonctionnaires qui
viennent de tous nos territoires de tous
nos villages de tout notre pays qu'ils
puissent préparer notamment à
l'université qu'ils puissent être formés
aux enjeux du 21e siècle qui puisse être
avec une culture commune où chacun
pourra travailler avec des gens qui sont
allés collectivités dans les hôpitaux
bref dans ce qui fait aujourd'hui
l'action publique et qu'ils puissent
ensuite ré évalué pour que nous gagnons
là aussi en capacité à faire du sur
mesure et que tous les français dans
tous les départements voient des
résultats sur tous les sujets c'est ça
notre enjeu mais ils m'ont chalon va
finir le temps presse sont à finir par
quelques questions politiques on a parlé
des élections départementales et
régionales
d'abord sur les élections
départementales vous êtes une figure de
la majorité présidentielle dans
l'essonne vous avez été élu député dans
l'essonne est ce que vous avez l'envié
d'être tête de liste de la majorité
présidentielle dans l'essonne au
départemental
moi je me m'engage pour les élections
régionales
je m'engagerai aux côtés de laurent
saint martin qui est notre candidat et
je m'engage dans ce territoire parce que
c'est un territoire où nous avons
absolument besoin de faire valoir des
idées un projet c'est une mini france
aux portes de paris
avec tout ce que la france comporte à la
fois d'opportunités mais aussi de défis
parfois de difficulté et dans ces
élections régionales en île de france
comme partout ailleurs dans le pays nous
avons un objectif porter des idées
présenter un projet et faire un peu
voyez cartes sur table avoir un discours
de réalité de vérité parce qu'on a
beaucoup d'opposants aujourd'hui qu'ils
ont trouvé que leur projet c'est se
battre contre l'état et que dire que
l'état ne fait pas l'état fait ceci il
est un vrai pas cela ce serait un projet
politique notre projet c'est pas qu'on
fasse cela guerre des collectivités
d'état c'est payet le méchant et à la
gentille collectivités ou inverse
il ya des hommes et des femmes qui ont
des responsabilités différentes qui
doivent travailler chaque jour ensemble
ensemble en train les merles aidée par
les départements les régions
chacun travaille ensemble avec des idées
des projets et donc c'est ce que nous
mettrons sur la table en ile de france
mais également dans l'ensemble du pays
la majorité présidentielle elle a déjà
beaucoup agi elle a des résultats qui
sont publiques des bons résultats
parfois des résultats un peu moins bon
et on assume pleinement on doit
accélérer et pour accélérer mais je peux
vous dire une chose si c'est la guerre
des collectivités compléta et
le projet c'est vous dire qu'en fait
quand c'est bien c'est vous et puis
quand c'est pas bien c'est les autres
ça ne marche pas il est français
d'ailleurs ceux des tons un politique
pour ça parce qu'il voulait que c'est
totalement politiciens et que ça
correspond pas à la réalité à mi chemin
là vous avez évoqué les régionales
notamment avec laurent saint martin je
vous repose ma question sur les
élections départementales dans l'essonne
est ce que vous souhaitez vous
participer à la bataille
moi je m'engage pour chasser c'est une
bataille pour les rejoins c'est une
sacrée bataille il ya des gens qui
sortent y ait des gens qui rentrent il
ya des idées il faut qu'on défend de
conviction quand donc des
départementales se passe le même jour je
peux vous dire qu'un certain nombre de
personnes de notre majorité vont
s'engager pour là aussi porter des idées
porteuses idéal pour le territoire et
donc on n'est pas en train d'envoyer de
faire du dégât jce on est en train de
proposer un projet parce que je crois
qu'en démocratie c'est le point de
départ si on est là pour se faire la
bataille les uns des autres des du
département comble et à l'arrivée ça ne
marche pas et donc c'est ça qu'on pose
évidemment je serai pleinement soutien
de ceux et celles qui s'engagent avec
nos idées avec notre projet est
également pleinement engagés moi-même
dans cette campagne pour une région qui
doit d'une région n'a envie de vivre une
région qui apporte de l'emploi qui est
de ces jeunes à préparer l'avenir qui se
bat pour l'égalité des chances tout ce
que je vous ai ni sur la haute fonction
publique
aujourd'hui on a une classe préparatoire
au concours de la haute fonction
publique a évolué à ses ouailles et
beaucoup de jeunes qui parfois c'était
beaucoup autocensuré équivaut se
préparent actuellement leur j'ai
encouragé j'espère qu'ils auront au
concours les respecte et souhaite qu'ils
se préparent à des concours et à des
métiers à des fonctions qui étaient
jusqu'à maintenant perçu comme réservés
à d'autres werner question à mes
dimanches à main il nous reste quelques
secondes le grand adversaire de la
république en marge de la majorité
présidentielle aux régionales c'est en
ile de france
c'est valérie pécresse vous avez
travaillé avec valérie pécresse est ce
que vous pourriez vous alliez à elle dès
le premier tour ou dès le second tour
aujourd'hui je vous dis les logique
d'alliance d'appareils et c'est
l'intérêt spa ni les français ni
français donc nous on a des idées on est
très sereins on a plein de propositions
à faire des choses assez novatrice sur
notamment la manière dont les
franciliens peuvent soutenir leur
économie
la manière dont nous travaillons nous
voulons travailler sur la sécurité la
manière dont nous voulait aussi aménagé
autrement notre région je pense que les
français ils attendent de nous envoyer
des idées des projets de l'engagement de
l'authenticité et sûrement pas qu'on
avait parlé
accords d'appareil et voyez des choses
qui se passent plutôt dans les couloirs
que face aux français sur une alliance
avec valérie pécresse ne me répondait
pas aujourd'hui je m'engage pourquoi
pour siéger dans un conseil régional
pour porter des idées pour former un
groupe pour défendre des idées on n'est
pas là pour chercher des places d'accord
donc on est engagée de manière
authentique et là aussi les choses
doivent se passer face aux français
c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que les
élections soient aussi avait pas
d'élection se mettre d'accord entre nous
et les élections on se présente on va au
bout de la bataille
on va au bout des élections et on sera
là aussi engagé sur un projet des idées
et on va en parler de ces élections dans
notre club des territoires dans quelques
minutes merci beaucoup à mes dimanche
alain d'avoir été notre invité politique
merci beaucoup
eric pour cette interview en partenariat
avec la nouvelle république est
d'ailleurs on va regarder à la une de la
nouvelle république
ce matin qui est consacrée à l'île de la
métairie près de tours qui permet
justement aux habitants de tours de
souffler un peu
pendant le confinement merci beaucoup
[Musique]